I opened his head yes or no I made him
think or reflect and literally open his
head he was holding
me on my shoulder I
did not calculate that he occupies a space to the
side of my body he says he hit
a gate five points on the
forehead
At that moment I felt like the teacher of the
world,
the truth is that I didn't know how to ask
for his forgiveness, luckily, the flea was one of those people
or is one of those people who take
things quite well and it is today
that he continues to say that I was a coach
who  he left the most important mark on his
career
the truth is that when I started working at the
institute for the blind
a lot of things surprised me a
lot of things that they did and I only
imagined that I could advance towards
swimming athletics with the tomato trick
they took that  yes they didn't burn
but when I saw that they play soccer it
seemed incredible to me to have a
dirt field with two rusty goals and
broken nets and the guys who armed the institute
in their soccer game  bowl
just like I did in the paddock on the
corner of the house but you have to play without
seeing the ball it had a sound so they
could locate it there was a guide that they
put behind the rival goal to know
where they had to kick they put on a
mask there was  some boys who had
a rest of vision so that they are all the
same
used is anti daughters when I gained a
little confidence with them I decided
to ask them for a mask
I put it on I tried to play I had
played soccer all my life it seemed
even more incredible to me  the two
seconds I didn't know where I was standing in
reality I only studied physical education
because I loved high performance I
had started working there by
chance and another job was with
the Argentine rowing team and I felt that
this was my thing
here it cost me all the time  double
I will never forget the first day
perhaps when the team warmed up
and I put them in front of me I had all the
experience of the rowing team and
I told them well  hour everyone downstairs
and sixth
when I looked up there were 260 23
other English lying down
how do I do the same thing I was
doing here it cost me a lot
I started looking for tools to learn from
them from the teachers to work with them
I learned that I couldn't explain a  played
on a blackboard like a technician does but I
could use a plastic tray
with caps so they can interpret me
through learned touch they
could also run an athletics track
if I ran with them I would take a sudden
so we started looking for volunteers
to help us  to run with them and I
started to like it and I was finding the
objective and the meaning of the activity. It was
uncomfortable at first but I
decided to overcome that discomfort and there came
a time when it was of all my
jobs that I am most passionate about, I think it was  there
when I asked myself why we could not
also make a
high-performance team with the blind, of
course the other part was missing h  I would have to
see what they wanted, the real
protagonists of this story, it does not
reach 3 hours on the little
dirt field where we play soccer, we had to
train in another way,
we began to demand it, and the response was
magnificent, I asked for more,
I understood that they are also
wondering why not  they could know high
performance when we felt
ready
we went to knock on the door of the cenard
national high performance center that
we have here in this country it cost us a
lot that they won't know but it cost us a
lot more that the other athletes
who trained there actually consider us
peers  it wasn't on the field
only when no other team
used it we looked at the higuitos they didn't
all know what we do there's inside the
2006 World Cup it was a turning point in the
team's history it
was the first time they were Buenos Aires it
was our opportunity to
show our team what  we had been doing
for a while we reached the final
we had been growing as a team and in the
the end on the other side was racing they
had been the best team in the tournament they
won every game by a landslide
almost no one trusted that we
could win that game
almost no one except us in the
concentration in the locker room at each
training
session fabiola champion I swear to you that it only exists
I only felt several times with the team
but I particularly remember the day
before playing that
Argentine soccer association final
the doors had opened and we are concentrated in
AFA where Perón and Uruguay were concentrated in
Messi
for us it was we felt a
real selection for the first time in  the
technical talk the day before
half past seven in the afternoon we were in
the room and a waiter knocks on the door
interrupting the talk to produce
a church does not want to invite in a
church tried to dissuade him by telling him
that it was not the best time we
leave it for another  for another day and in
there telling me to please
let them take the boys to church  esia
because it is said a pastor who performed
miracles
I asked him with a little fear
what miracle he was referring to and very loosely he
told me teacher let the church team improve
and when we return I am sure
that half
b heard some laughter because
imagine  some and today they are
telling him that I did not know what to answer him
I stayed married he made a
slightly awkward silence I did not want to make him
feel bad because he really believed that
it could happen and he took me out because
of one of the players who got up and very
sure juan aisle told the mosso
things he said that it is not the best time
to go to church but he makes it clear that
we will come to church and when
we return I am among half of those who
sees terry I [ __ ] because tomorrow
he couldn't play  the game
juan left seeing if there is something resigned
we continue with the technical talk and that
night when I went to sleep
I began to dream in my head the game
the next day imagine what I could
pass how we are going to play and that is where
the now champion feel that you tell him for
a little while because at that moment I felt
that if the rest of the players had
the same desire to play that
game as I do, we could not be champions
the next day would be  wonderful we got
up at 9 in the morning
from 7 in the evening and we
wanted to go play
we left the afa and the microphone was
full of flags that people had given us
we were talking about the game and
listening to the honks and shouts  of people
who did not want bats today is the
last day last effort
the boys asked me less they know they
know that we played
there were people who were going to dinner following the
bus
we arrived and we found an
incredible setting and on the way from the locker room
to the field
I came  walking council holding my
shoulder guiding him luckily there weren't
any gates on the road and
when we got to the court he
asked me everything I don't know  I wasn't going to lose
a single detail
so he said tell me what time he's
also playing his drums and I
tried to apply as much detail as
possible what was happening then he said and
even the stands full of a
lot of people outside and then
blue and white all over the court
they are opening a giant flag of
argentina that occupies the entire grandstand
in a moment it breaks you and tells me see
if it is a flag that said san pedro the
city where he lives i
start looking in the grandstand and
above plane cheetah white and painted
with black spray  a flag that said
silvio his family landmark san pedro
present I tell him and he tells me there
is my old lady
please tell me where she is I want to say
hello he accommodated him and with his arm he
pointed
to the flag and with his arms the
greeting towards that place was  Some
20 to 30 people stand up to applaud him
and when this happens, but how
his face changes as he gets excited,
obviously I got excited too, but
the two seconds made me  or a lump in
the throat
is rare because I felt the emotion of what
was happening and the anger and anguish
that he could not see all this a
few days later when I talked with
him I told him what had happened to
me he calmed me down because I  he said
calmly I saw them and in a different way but
I swear I saw everyone
the game started we can't break it
was the final the people had to
be silent like now because in
football it's god
the public has to do  this silence
for them to hear the ball and they had to
enter only when the game
was stopped,
yes, with eight minutes to
go they avoided everything that had not been
removed in 32 from the soul when the
boy silvio nailed it in the angle they
removed that goal once  incredible way if you
go to dinner and go through the door you will
see a huge billboard with the picture of the
bats they are a model selection of the
country
everyone knows who they are in the senate and
after having won two championships
world champions and two Paralympic medals
no one doubts that they are high performance
I was lucky enough to train this team
first as a physical trainer then
as a technical director for ten years
the feeling that I get or that I have is
that they receive much more than what they give
I saw last year they proposed to me to deliver
another selection, the power char soccer team
is an Argentine team of boys who
play soccer in wheelchairs are
motorized wheelchairs that drive
with a joystick because they do not have the strength
in their arms to propel a
chair  conventional and they put
the chair as a bumper with a defense that in
addition to protecting their feet allows them to
kick the ball it is the first time that
they stop being spectators to be
protagonists
the first time that their parents their friends
their brothers can go to see play  to
them for me it is a new challenge
back to the discomfort the insecurity
the fears that when I started with the
blind if I cold  He came with more
experience
I think that's why from the first day he
treats them like athletes inside the
field and trying to put myself in their
place outside without any prejudice
because as they are treated naturally
the better they feel
the two teams play football it was
something unthinkable for them they had to
adapt the rules to be able to do it yes
and they broke two teams with the same
rule
precisely that if they couldn't
play soccer when they don't see him play or no
competition disability
the problem is when that
game ends and leave the  court and they go out to
play our game in a society
that establishes rules that take them very
little into account that their
apprentice of the sport does not take care of them and disability
depends largely on the rules of the
game
that is why I think that if we change some of
the rules  of our party we can
make life a little easier facts
we all know that there are
people with disabilities we see them on a
daily basis but  hen we do not have
direct contact with them, we are not
aware of the problems they
face on a daily basis what it costs them to
get on a bus to get a
job they got off the subway to cross a street it
is true that there is a greater
social responsibility
with regard to  the inclusion
of people with disabilities but I think
that is not enough I still believe that the
change must be up to each one of us
first leaving aside indifference
towards them and then respecting the
rules that do take them into account that they
are few but oh me  I opened the
head of a blind man
'the flea' I can assure you that all
teams also opened me up because
they taught me above all how to
go out and play each game
in this beautiful championship that is
life thanks